welcome to this video it's a five-minute
game again only if the opponent is
really playing and I was playing the
national master Willie Mays from what's
this we need so you know I actually
would have guessed with it so Anna but
Willie Mays don't know let's have a look
I don't yo palacios don't know this guy
then wondering about Willie Mays listen
Neymar should be familiar with some
well-known person okay are we have an
English opening here playing what is
usually called the cap off system with
Bishop c5 this was played them quite
often by the former world champion it
leads to a position or positions where
black usually is so quite solid quite it
fits sir the form of our champions star
nicely like that some good development
and there should be six queen d 7 s own
an idea it's a quite funny that blacks
position is almost identical to the
setup you have in the in the Italian
game the JUCO piano while white setup is
of course are completely different okay
um I'd like to play Bishop is six but
maybe there's be fire yeah let's
unprotect be seven
not sure if this was necessary but
shouldn't be too awful yeah this is so
also quite quite common this manoeuvre
right to you six sometimes you can go to
g5 and plans like that so yes maybe in
10 need to just take on a sec
click on I'd see five-headed defaults
not good maybe I should do that simply
the tech and play Bishop f5 next
attacking d3 maybe I can provoke efore
on a piece going to e form to exchange
some of that yes this was also possible
at him this was my idea getting some
pressure against the depot it's also not
a bad bet diagonal is also on the rook
so we cannot easily play deform and
attack the bishop
okay yeah he's going out of the sir this
this pin basically the spawn was pinned
mmm Queen d7 sd4 problem I can always go
back to 2am it's not a big deal I think
from Bishop to h3 if I if I am able to
exchange the bishops this would be a
huge step forward okay let's try that
you can't play Bishop h1 but then I have
ideas like Bishop g4 bit a bit annoying
fan yeah let's do that f3 is not great
enter maybe I can simply may be I can
even play Queen f5 here yeah Queen f5
maybe still preventing deform due to the
pin and you can maybe play f3 then I can
go to h3 empty why not let's do that
it's annoying and Queen h5 is the threat
at least I believe so Queen age five and
then Bishop to f3
nice very very relaxed about all this I
thought this would be annoying
before I've got Quinn age five if I has
a stupid move anyway f2a saying
not sure if I could take it but it's
it's it's it's I can take you from
before so not playable at all but this
also means that turn uh-huh I wonder I
wonder I want an IG forest Nancy for
more oops not this let's let's do that
why not activate
we got this was probably necessary um if
I go Queen h5 is playing age three can I
can take but it doesn't really help
and that's not really improved in my
position okay that's let's clarify this
host him interesting I didn't expect
that at all why take with I take with
the Rakuten much um can also just take
this here don't see why not you can go
95 but I think I can just play Queen
back
27 or something
yeah I guess you over look at this
hanging porn he's so taking some time
here for the reply
yeah I think stuff like Queen age 5 is
not really not really AM effectively can
play h3 and then I don't have an attack
me it's not moving okay all the way back
here probably age 39 f six
he's getting back this porn probably I
could play c6 though yeah why not attack
the look if the rook moves I have a
tempo even with Bishop c5 I have to get
the night the same ah not really awake
ok I can take here maybe this is better
even I just just go to see five that's
probably both good now it's not speeding
up at all I mean I'm very often doing
the same thing but it's very it's down
on nine seconds and it's not moving well
this is nice no I could take the roku no
violence let's just let's keep it simple
like four hits on time yeah i think by
now Black is indeed clearly better I'm
not quite sure where ok he gave me a 3
which was helpful of course maybe I
should have taken on be fine earlier but
this is not not a bad plan exchanging
the bishop or trying to exchange it not
sure about this this in in retrospect
yeah but it's not bad this plan what you
should f3 should be ok for me yeah maybe
this isn't so effective as well but it
always was quite ok for me nothing
spectacular but oh in factor the
computer points out that this is good
for white this is surprising
why exactly oh yeah yeah this is good
the computer now points out a good move
for white they can play d4 him deform
gather some make sure that I'm not
easily retreating yeah and c6 can be
answered with this okay no I didn't see
that so I could I couldn't take on a
three it's a really a mistake you spent
a long while but you didn't find the
form mmm yeah it's not not easy garant
around here I'm just material up with no
particular compensation yeah this is
very nice not for white or black it's
it's a double pond but it's a very
strong Center and I have this efore idea
which is very important to fix these
bones on dark squares and alumni t5 I
mean fixing on dark squares one thing
but his light squares are very weak so
let's say something something like this
is it's the point this is a dear yeah
alright thanks for watching